depuis 1958 les députés sont élus au
scrutin uninominal majoritaire à deux
tours
les français sont retournés aux urnes
pour élire les nouveaux députés qui
composeront le premier parlement de la
5e république
en pratique les électeurs votent pour un
candidat et non pour une liste et pour
être élu il faut la majorité des voix ce
scrutin instaurée par le général de
gaulle se veut le garant d'une assemblée
stable avec une majorité claire mais la
conséquence c'est qu'il favorise les
grands partis en 1985 françois
mitterrand laisse entendre un changement
l'infusart et à des degrés divers de la
proportionnelle dans la plupart de nos
modes de scrutin plus qu'un fusée c'est
une proportionnelle intégrale qui sera
appliquée lors des législatives de 1986
le président espère empêcher la droite
d'avoir une majorité à l'assemblée car
avec ce scrutin ce sont des listes de
candidats qui gagnent des sièges à
l'assemblée en proportion des voix
qu'elle reçoive une occasion pour les
petits partis d'entrer dans l'hémicycle
résultat en 1986
situation inédite sous la vème
république le parti socialiste la mer
gèle n'aurait plus la majorité absolue
les socialistes perdent la majorité à
l'assemblée la droite l'emportent et le
front national entre en force pour la
première fois avec 35 députés c'est donc
un échec pour françois mitterrand qui se
solde par une cohabitation jacques
chirac devient premier ministre et
aussitôt il revient sur le mode de
scrutin des législatives le gouvernement
de jacques chirac a déposé cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale son projet
de réforme de la loi électorale le
scrutin majoritaire à deux tours
pourrait donc être réinstaurée à l'issue
du débat parlementaire et il le sera
mais les petits partis n'ont depuis
jamais cessé de plaider pour le retour
de la proportionnelle ils font valoir
l'argument de la représentation
démocratique avec le scrutin majoritaire
à deux tours les partis dominants sont
sur représentés
les partis comme le front national où la
france un sou mais sont sous représentés
voilà le résultat si la proportionnelle
était intégrale les rapports de force
vous le voyez change beaucoup mais c'est
plutôt une dose de proportionnelle qui
est envisagée cette dose de
proportionnelle aux législatives
c'est une promesse récurrente des
candidats à la présidentielle une
manière de séduire les électeurs des
petits partis
je m'engage à réunir toutes les forces
politiques de la nation et à discuter
avec elle de la possibilité d'introduire
un peu de proportionnelle
part de proportionnelle à l'assemblée
nationale je proposerai ainsi que le
parlement soit élu avec une dose de
proportionnelle
des promesses jamais tenues
[Musique]